MALE SPEAKER: Very
warm welcome.
We're going to be discussing
everything monsters today.
I thought I'd start--
I spent the first 10 minutes
writing down some monster
jokes to whip you into
a monster frenzy.
OK.
Why couldn't the monster
buy a pair of shoes?
DAN SCANLON: Why?
KORI RAE: He didn't have feet.
MALE SPEAKER: Because
he had a big foot.
KORI RAE: Ah.
DAN SCANLON: Ah.
That's gold.
It's not too late to get
that in the movie.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: It
does get worse.
Why did the monster transfer
jobs so easily?
DAN SCANLON: I don't know.
MALE SPEAKER: Because of the
claws in his contract.
DAN SCANLON: Ah.
MALE SPEAKER: That's
terrible, isn't it?
DAN SCANLON: Much worse.
KORI RAE: Nice.
MALE SPEAKER: Last
one, I promise.
Why couldn't the monster
get into his apartment?
This one needs a bit of work.
DAN SCANLON: OK.
KORI RAE: The others didn't.
DAN SCANLON: Yeah, yeah.
The others are great.
MALE SPEAKER: Why couldn't
the monster--
now I haven't--
there is a punchline.
DAN SCANLON: OK.
KORI RAE: OK.
MALE SPEAKER: He couldn't get
into his apartment because of
the Lock Ness Monster.
KORI RAE: Oh.
DAN SCANLON: Yeah.
Except that--
OK.
We'll work on that.
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
I wrote down
applause and I got a little.
DAN SCANLON: Oh look at that.
You wrote down applause.
With an actual pause
for those jokes.
It's very professional.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So thankfully you're not here
to listen to these jokes.
We're actually here to meet the
creators of this, which
will either be awkward
silence or a trailer.
So we're very lucky to have
the director of "Monsters
University," Dan Scanlon, and
Kori Rae, the producer.
KORI RAE: Hello.
MALE SPEAKER: Maybe I'll ask
you to introduce a bit more
about yourselves in a minute,
but the first question is how
does it feel seeing that?
DAN SCANLON: Oh, it's great.
It's fun to watch the trailer
with an audience.
I don't think we've
ever done that.
KORI RAE: I know.
DAN SCANLON: Yeah.
We're so excited that
the movie's done.
We spent so much time
working on it.
We spend almost five years
working on each individual
film at Pixar.
And so to finally have the movie
coming out in two days
and to be able to share
it with the
world is very exciting.
MALE SPEAKER: Wow.
From a production point of view,
the amount of work that
goes into that-- is that
a relief to see
how amazing it is?
KORI RAE: It is.
And it's been interesting
in the last few weeks.
It's almost bittersweet when
it's over because you do spend
so much time with the crew
and so much time on the
production.
And it's a little bit of an odd
departure when it's over
so we're still experiencing
a little bit of that.
But super-excited to get
it out to the world.
Can't wait.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
So we may open up some questions
we have maybe 20
minutes left.
So I was hopefully going to
go through some topics.
I was kind of interested in how
you arrived at Pixar on
your journey and a little bit
about your education and
inspirations.
DAN SCANLON: Yeah, in my case
I always loved to draw, got
really into film and animation
when I was young.
I went to college in
Ohio studying--
actually studying illustration
and kind of fell
off film for awhile.
But then I get a job at this
company in Ohio called
Character Builders that did a
lot of direct-to-video Disney
sequels, "The Little Mermaid
II" and "101 Dalmatians II"
and all those.
But it was great.
It was a great experience
because we had to make the
movies for half the budget
and half the time.
Frankly even knowing that you're
making a movie that
people didn't want to exist.
The people didn't want
those movies.
But I liked that.
I liked kind of the underdog
nature of, all right we're
going to try to make these
as good as we can.
And then I left there and I
applied to as many places as I
could because I just wanted to
try to move to California.
To try to really go for it.
And I applied at all these
different places.
And I applied at Pixar as
sort of the joke one.
Like well, I guess it wouldn't
hurt to get my
name on a form somewhere.
And no one replied to
me except for Pixar.
And it was such a great example
of just go for whatever.
Go for everything you want
because you never know.
And luckily they brought me in
to work on "Cars"-- the first
"Cars."
And in my interview with Joe
Ranft, who was a great story
artist there, he said, oh you're
from the Detroit area.
I bet you're really good
at drawing cars.
I didn't know what the movie
was going to be about yet.
And I said, oh to be honest with
you I hate drawing cars.
I don't know how to do it.
That's why I'm leaving
Detroit.
I couldn't draw a car
to save my life.
And then I said, the movie's
called "Cars"?
I was like, ohh.
Oh.
And so, yeah "Monsters Inc," the
first one, actually came
out the first month that
I worked at Pixar.
And I got to go to the wrap
party and it was just such a
dream to be there.
And then I worked on "Toy
Story" and made my own
live-action film feature
called "Tracy" on the
weekends, with other people from
Pixar, just as practice
writing and directing
a feature on my own.
And I think that helped
me get this job.
MALE SPEAKER: So the inspiration
was Disney when
you were a child--
sort of growing up with the old
classic [INAUDIBLE] films.
DAN SCANLON: A lot of it was
more Warner Bros., Chuck
Jones, Tex Avery-- that
kind of stuff.
But I was a fan of the shorts
Pixar was doing.
And I was a fan of Aardman, the
shorts that Aardman was
doing at the time.
MALE SPEAKER: That's great.
And Kori, in terms of producing,
did you start small
and then work into
big scale film?
KORI RAE: Yeah, I started
at the very bottom.
I got in on the ground floor
about 20 years ago when we
used to produce commercials.
And I applied for an assistant
to the executive producer of
the Commercials Group and went
up against a couple of
internal people.
And I had a little bit of a
writing background and project
management background, so
somehow they hired me.
And then I kind of quickly
worked my way up in the
Commercial Group and started
producing commercials until
"Toy Story" came out.
And they took all of our
people that were in the
Commercials Group, all 12 or
13, just to finish "Toy
Story." And then once it was
released and Disney said well
maybe we might help--
if you want to make another
movie, maybe.
So that's when we kind of
closed up shop in the
Commercial Group and I moved
over and started working on "A
Bug's Life" as the animation
manager.
So that was my first
feature film.
And then I've worked on a bunch
since then, and this is
my first full producing gig.
I was a development producer
on "Up" but just
for the first year.
MALE SPEAKER: What's really
astounding I think, watching
Pixar movies, is the incredible
amount of detail
and love and passion that
goes into those films.
And also how complex it must
be from the beginning of a
storyboard through to
the finished piece.
But just a little bit on that
process, do you still
traditionally begin with the
drawings and the gag drawings
the way that the old Disney
films were made and the old
Warner Bros. films?
DAN SCANLON: Yeah.
KORI RAE: Yeah.
DAN SCANLON: Absolutely.
KORI RAE: Absolutely, yeah.
We did over 200,000 storyboards
for this film.
So--
DAN SCANLON: Oops.
KORI RAE: For better or worse.
DAN SCANLON: I couldn't
make up my mind.
Yeah, we'd still do a ton
of hand-drawn stuff.
Even our storyboards--
and when I started on "Cars"
our storyboards were
completely hand-drawn on paper
and pasted to the wall, and we
pointed at them with
an old stick.
It feels like an incredibly
outdated thing now, but the
world changed fast.
And now we're drawing
on Cintiqs.
But you know in the art
department people still draw
on paper every now and then.
KORI RAE: Yep.
DAN SCANLON: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: And I guess
because the actual process of
these animation renderings is
very expensive, you really try
and get the lock down
on these finished
animatics to begin with.
So you've pretty much got the
whole story working before you
move forward.
KORI RAE: At least
segments of it.
You know what I mean.
We certainly put the story reels
up over and over again a
lot the first two
years at least--
like every three months.
We'd put them, up we show
them to the internal
kind of brain trust--
all the directors at Pixar.
Then they give a bunch of notes,
we tear them down and
we start all over.
And we do that every
three months or so.
And then slowly we--
and along with that
we do design.
We start design pretty
early-on as well--
production design.
And then it kind of gets into
production from there.
MALE SPEAKER: So you're kind of
building everything up bit
by bit, but occasionally
going back in.
KORI RAE: Yeah, for sure.
MALE SPEAKER: So I guess you
took this template but then
you also thought we want this
idea for a sequel, but we
don't want a sequel
we want a prequel.
How did that come about?
DAN SCANLON: About five years
ago we started thinking about
it for the first time.
Just the idea that we loved
these characters and wanted to
see if there was even an
idea there worth doing.
So a bunch of us got together,
including John Lasseter and
Pete Docter who wrote the
original-- or I mean that
directed the original film--
the original writers
were there.
And we thought if we were going
to do a story with these
characters we wanted to do
something that explored their
relationship more.
And that was really where we got
the idea of well we should
go back in time and actually
see how the
relationship developed.
And obviously from that idea
we loved the entertainment
possibility of college,
monster college.
But the real heart of it for
us was when we realized we
could tell the story
about Mike.
And the movie is very
much Mike's story.
It's a movie about these guys
coming together but our main
character this time is Mike.
And we found that prequels are
tough because you more or less
know how the movie's going to
end and that everyone's going
to survive.
And so we wanted to tell a story
where knowing the ending
at the beginning of the movie
was a good thing.
We wanted to tell a story about
a character who doesn't
get everything he wants
in the end.
There are so many movies that
say if you work hard and never
give up everything will
always turn out great.
And even though that's a great
message it's just sadly it's
not always true.
And so many of us that
experienced that in our weird
past to our careers, that we'd
had these big dreams that were
kind of dashed.
And at the time it seemed
devastating, but we look back
on it now and realize
well it actually led
to something better.
And we wanted to tell
that story.
So it's really the story of Mike
desperately wanting to be
a scarer more than anything
in his life.
And then the audience
knowing he's headed
for kind of a disaster.
That seemed so interesting
to us.
To tell a story that was a
little controversial and we
hadn't quite seen before.
And that's where the gist
of the idea came from.
MALE SPEAKER: It was sort of a
wonderful surprise watching
the film thinking that
we do know, kind of
in a way, what happens.
But actually it's just
this great snapshot
of life on an American--
in an American university.
Was there ever a slight worry
that you were thinking would
this translate globally, this
idea of universities?
Not for me, I remember growing
up in the UK with programs
like "The Wonder Years," and I
had this idea of what American
college was like.
DAN SCANLON: That's
so funny as we
started to talk to people.
Well number one we thought you
really just need to know
there's fraternities and
sororities in the movie.
But I think as long as you
see them as teams--
KORI RAE: Teams or
clubs, yeah.
DAN SCANLON: --it makes sense.
Then the more people we talked
to would say exactly what you
said like, well I know what it
is from American movies.
And I'd think, yeah that's the
only reason I know what it is.
Like the college I went to
was nothing like that.
We went to art school.
They didn't have fraternities or
sororities or any of that.
KORI RAE: Yeah.
DAN SCANLON: So it seemed like
it's being received well
regardless of that.
MALE SPEAKER: And I
think-- sorry--
KORI RAE: Oh no, I was just
going to say because the film
is really about self-discovery.
And it's really about that time
in your life when you're
18-19 years old, kind of out on
your own for the first time
figuring stuff out.
And so we have found that it
still is a pretty universal
story and a pretty universal
message, even though it takes
place on a college campus.
Even if that part isn't quite
familiar with people.
We think the story
still resonates.
MALE SPEAKER: It has this
great bit where you're
introduced to all these
different frat parties that
have all these different
sort of personalities.
I think we may have a clip, the
ROR Trailer, of meeting
one of the other sort
of gangs on campus.
KORI RAE: Yeah exactly.
BACKGROUND SPEAKER:
Do you want to
do initiation reports--
MALE SPEAKER: We can
show initiation.
I was going to ask you if
this was your initiation
ceremony for Pixar.
DAN SCANLON: Right, yes.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, so we'll
run the other one.
And just on the characters--
it looks like you had an
absolute blast creating and
designing these, because it's
a world where anything can
happen, right?
DAN SCANLON: Yeah,
oh for sure.
We have a great art
department.
And you know the first thing
we really do is think about
the characters themselves, what
they need to be in order
to tell the story, and then
we start designing them.
And it is tough.
In the case of "Monsters" it's
fun because it can be anything
and it's hard because
it can be anything.
It's hard to figure out
what to hold onto.
Yeah, we had a great time
with this team.
We have a new character, the
dean in the movie Dean
Hardscrabble, who had to be
one of the most terrifying
scarers of all time.
And so we really wanted to
design something that was
really freaky looking.
We got on the topic of bugs.
Bugs are creepy.
And we found this thing--
it's a giant centipede, it's a
real thing that exists in the
world-- and we rented one.
And they brought it--
KORI RAE: We weren't
going to buy one.
We weren't going to keep it.
DAN SCANLON: No.
Yeah, and they brought it into
meetings in what looked like a
plastic jar that had
potato salad in it.
It was so not official with a
little bit of tape on it.
This doesn't seem right that one
of the interns is taking
care of this thing.
And they said, the guy that
brought it said, if it bites
you you won't die but you'll
wish you were dead.
So we would have this thing
around all the time.
But it was really great to
research to have it there.
MALE SPEAKER: And it's also
interesting because the other
world, the animation world,
gives you sort of the
opportunity to make
things move in
completely different ways.
And that's what I also loved
about this film--
you had the opportunity to play
with short legs, long
legs, millipedes, giant--
It's an opportunity for the
animators to really sort of
get their teeth into it.
DAN SCANLON: Yeah.
KORI RAE: Yeah.
DAN SCANLON: Oh yeah, I mean
animation-wise it was each one
of these things-- once you
develop a new-looking
character, now you have to
figure out how it moves.
And again they're all things
that we've never really seen
before necessarily.
Tentacles are very
hard, apparently.
KORI RAE: For sure.
Yeah, I think just the scope of
this film and the different
body types.
It was actually one of the most
challenging things about
the film, technically.
Where just the different-- the
number of different types of
monsters, and the way that
they moved, and the
locomotion of them.
It was because there's dozens
and hundreds of
monsters in each shot.
And they all move differently.
So you have to--
the animator has to animate
Terri and Terry with
tentacles, and they have to
animate Squishy that just kind
of has squishy legs, and Art
who moves in a weird way.
DAN SCANLON: Yeah, he's
sort of the purple
thing you saw in that--
KORI RAE: U-shaped guy.
DAN SCANLON: Yeah.
KORI RAE: Yeah.
DAN SCANLON: And that was great
because the animators
would almost kind of test
themselves and who could come
up with the weirdest thing
for Art to do.
It was just very fun
to explore that.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, it's
beautiful to watch.
And also I think the other thing
that stood out was the
attention to detail which
is always there
in these Pixar films.
But I'd never seen
anything like--
there was almost dust
particles I noticed.
There's a part where Mike writes
in his calendar and
that the pen absorbs
into the calendar.
It's almost like--
that's incredible.
I mean how far can that
technology go?
DAN SCANLON: I don't know.
KORI RAE: I don't know.
It's amazing.
I think it's that the artists
are really pushing themselves
all the time.
This isn't like Dan--
I don't think Dan was in the
review going, OK now make sure
that that marker really
seeps in there.
It's everybody challenging
themselves.
And that's--
like this environment, it's
similar at Pixar--
we're just always trying
to push individually.
All the artists are pushing
themselves to do something
cooler than last time.
Or add that little touch at
the very end of the shot.
And it's remarkable.
I mean that is what all
adds up to that
incredible level of detail.
Again most of it
isn't planned.
Some of it is.
And a lot of it just happens
because the artists
are who they are.
So it's cool that way.
MALE SPEAKER: So like with
"Nemo" it was water, and this
particular problem may have been
tentacles and the amount
of monsters on the show.
KORI RAE: Yeah, it was kind of
the amount of characters was
the big challenge.
DAN SCANLON: That and apparently
backpacks.
KORI RAE: Backpacks.
DAN SCANLON: At some
point backpacks are
really hard to simulate.
And put a backpack on
a hair creature.
But I felt bad because it's
well it's college--
they don't wear clothes.
So what else is going
to show you that
they're college students?
So it's not as sexy and exciting
as a giant ocean of
water and flames, but backpacks
were tough.
So if you see a backpack,
applaud.
MALE SPEAKER: And also I think
that the world of the
university--
I was kind of intrigued
as to--
does it completely exist
somewhere in a CG.
What's the level that
you went to to plan
out this giant campus.
KORI RAE: Yes, a lot.
We did have--
we had an actual model upfront
just trying to figure out the
whole layout of the campus.
And then we did go ahead and
put that into the computer.
I mean there's cheats here and
there where we needed for
specific scenes.
But yeah, it was definitely--
and that was painstaking.
Because the story has to drive
that, and the story has to be
to a certain point where you can
say, great this building
is here and this one's here.
And then we'd say, hey
Dan, what's going to
happen in this building?
And he'd say, I don't know.
I don't know yet.
We haven't figured it out.
DAN SCANLON: Yeah.
KORI RAE: So it's the
chick and egg thing.
Yeah.
DAN SCANLON: And that's what's
great about the sets
department and everyone, is
they know that the story
change trumps everything.
And sometimes it's sad.
Sometimes you've worked really
hard on something and you
think, that building can't
be over there anymore.
We made this change.
We gotta move that building, or
get rid of that building,
or get rid of that character.
And it's tough.
But I think people understand
that it's all in favor of
making a good story.
And nobody wants to just keep
something in the movie
because it's cool.
KORI RAE: Right.
DAN SCANLON: And we
worked hard on it.
You know, they want
it to be right.
KORI RAE: That's true.
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: So going back to
the story, was there one
particular part that you
may have been stuck on?
Was it the third act, or the
middle act, or the first?
DAN SCANLON: You know--
well thinking of it in acts--
the middle probably.
KORI RAE: I think
the middle was.
DAN SCANLON: It's funny, every
Pixar movie has that.
Where you think, ooh this
movie's going to have a tough
first act or a tough
third act.
I think a tough middle is
what you want, if you
have to have something.
As long as the movie starts
pretty good and ends pretty
good, who cares what happens
in the middle.
You end up going to the
bathroom, you get popcorn.
But the real danger
is when you've got
screwed-up third act.
Because that's the whole
point of the movie.
But it happens all the time.
You just bang your
head against the
wall to get it working.
KORI RAE: Right.
MALE SPEAKER: It seems like it's
such a process of getting
the script writers and then also
there's this I guess this
is reality of when you get the
guys in to do the voice-overs.
There may be a chemistry or
something that emerges from
there which can springboard
to another idea.
So it's sort of organic in a
way, but it also has so much
riding on it I guess.
I mean--
I have a question on pressure
which I underlined three
times, the word pressure, just
to sort of heighten it up.
DAN SCANLON: You wrote it
in the form of a joke.
MALE SPEAKER: In the
joke-- no, no.
It's not a joke.
No more jokes.
But I mean you're a director
of the most successful film
company in history.
Is there a level of--
is there a level of pressure
that you feel?
DAN SCANLON: I think that we--
we're pretty supported
at Pixar.
It's a very supportive place.
I always feel like we're
all in it together.
It's not competitive you know.
We try not to look at our movies
next to the other one
and that type of thing.
Everyone is so excited about
whatever individual movie is
coming out that you--
I don't know-- you really don't
think about it as much.
I think we're trying to make
movies that we like.
Because at first, our first
audience is ourselves.
It's the company.
And we're trying to make
a movie that we like.
And we honestly believe and
hope that if we do that,
hopefully we'll connect with
people rather than trying to
judge what the world
wants right now.
I think that's always kind of
a dangerous road to go down.
But I don't know.
Everyone keeps asking me if
I feel this pressure.
I feel like I should
probably feel it.
I do now.
KORI RAE: I think part of it
is that there's pressure at
the beginning in it because it's
just getting the story
off the ground in any
way shape or form
is the hardest part.
And then there's no time.
There's no time to think if
you're really moving forward.
There's no time to even think
about the pressure.
It's so crazy how jam packed the
production schedule is--
even at four years.
It's almost like you just put
your head down and, uh.
DAN SCANLON: Luckily we'll have
plenty of time on Friday
afternoon to refresh
rotten tomatoes.
KORI RAE: I'm not doing that.
MALE SPEAKER: I mean I
definitely haven't seen a film
where I've kind of like smiled
all the way through it.
It's just like a really
enjoyable film.
Once you're into the world
and that's it.
So I don't envision too many
bad reviews really.
Did you want to run the clip of
the ROR trailer because I
think it's interesting to talk
about the little different
frat gangs that appear.
Actually, there's like a real
opportunity to develop those
different personalities and
characters within that.
Is that based on the frat
gangs where you
were growing up?
DAN SCANLON: Yeah, I mean I
think some of it is based on
our own experiences and then
just sort of those classic
college archetypes with the
monster twist on them.
But yeah, I mean that was the
fun of having the fraternities
and sororities in the movie,
was to be able to just
celebrate those kind of classic
college cliches and types.
MALE SPEAKER: I love the
guy with the lisp.
DAN SCANLON: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: I did used to
hear Pixar stories that
occasionally some of the traits
of animators or people
that work there found their
way into the characters.
No one at Pixar with a lisp?
DAN SCANLON: No, not
that I would say.
KORI RAE: No.
But I think Bobby Moynihan
who voiced the character
of Chet kind of--
DAN SCANLON: He adds a lot.
KORI RAE: He adds
a lot to that.
He came up with that I think.
I mean you directed it, but
it's kind of his thing.
He's so great.
MALE SPEAKER: So now the
film is finished.
You get this chance to maybe
take a bit of a breather
before you begin to sort of
build up the energy to take on
something else.
DAN SCANLON: Yeah, absolutely.
I'm going to take
some time off.
KORI RAE: Exactly.
A little bit.
DAN SCANLON: Yeah.
KORI RAE: And then, yeah, come
back and then we'll go into
development and see if we can
come up with another idea--
MALE SPEAKER: That's
fantastic.
KORI RAE: --for another movie.
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: In terms of
questions we only have sort of
15-20 minutes left.
So if anyone would like to cue
up that would be fantastic.
AUDIENCE: I read that this is
the first Pixar movie that
makes full use so ray tracing?
I'm wondering if you could
discuss how that affected the
creative process with
movie making?
KORI RAE: Yeah, I mean yeah.
Global illumination and that--
we've kind of did a bunch of R
& D at the beginning.
And we've used that for the
first time on this film.
DAN SCANLON: Yeah, and
it's beautiful.
I mean we love the look of it.
It works really well for
this particular film.
It allows us to, or it allowed
me to see scenes lit kind of
quicker and more specifically.
Which allowed us to tell a story
with light in a way that
we really wanted to do.
Which just makes everything
easier I felt.
And Pete Docter was the
executive producer on this
film and he was a big mentor
for me the whole time.
And he would come in, and once
a week, and look at character
designs and animation.
And it had been 12 years since
he did his film and they did
it on a Texas Instrument
computer.
He would look at what I
get to see and he'd
go, you're so lucky.
You have it so easy.
When he would see character
designs they were sort of
frozen in this weird shape and
made out of simple things.
And I'd see them they'd be posed
in a production pose
with a drop shadow on it.
I'm like sure, that
looks good.
So easy.
Sorry.
KORI RAE: That's true.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks so much for coming.
So the past three out of four
Pixar movies have been either
sequels or prequels.
So my question is why, and what
are the challenges of
coming up with new stories
when there's
already existing material?
KORI RAE: Yeah, I mean we're
kind of lucky to be able to
make more movies than
we could years ago.
And we're able to go back into
these worlds and tell new
stories with existing characters
and worlds that we
created a while ago.
So we're actually excited
to go back into a
lot of these worlds.
And we're also excited to
tell original stories.
We're just happy to
be doing both.
But I think certainly
sequels and prequels
offer another challenge.
Because it's--
you have to kind of deal with
predictability and everything
that goes before, and come up
with brand new ideas that will
keep the audience interested.
So it's challenging.
But I think we're really glad
that we're able to do both.
And move forward doing both.
DAN SCANLON: We finally
have that luxury.
But sequels can be tough.
I mean we've said, it's like
it's as if someone took the
game chess and said, OK use all
these pieces but come up
with a different game that's
just as good as chess but
isn't chess.
But you can't change the
characters that much.
It's this other challenge.
AUDIENCE: This kind of
goes back to that
pressure question earlier.
So it seems like the tradition
that Pixar staff, co-directors
of past feature films or short
films, step into director's
chair such as Pete and Andrew.
So how much did co-directing
that short film for "Cars"
help you step into the
director's chair this time?
And also what does that say
about Pixar to have that much
trust and confidence in somebody
with their immaculate
track record?
DAN SCANLON: Yeah.
Jesus.
Pressure you guys
are putting on.
I co-directed "Mater and the
Ghost Site" which was a short
on the DVD several years ago.
But with John, so I mean
you couldn't really
have a better teacher.
It's different than making
an original short.
Those shorts, by the time we
do those, the whole team
you're with are so good
in that world.
And the animators know how to
animate those characters.
That ship kind of
sails itself.
It's a really great jumping off
point, but it is a whole
different world than
making a feature.
I mean most the assets
already exist.
I think we made a
lamp for that.
That was like the only
thing we made.
I look back on it a little bit,
I was probably strutting
around going, I co-directed a
movie, and not realizing, no
you didn't.
You kind of did, but yeah.
But I actually think that more
the years in story are where
the trust comes from.
Because story is the most
important thing when directing
a movie because all
your decisions
go back to the story.
You don't have to know
everything about animation, or
lighting, or how the
computer works.
You just have to know how to
explain the emotions that you
want and to know how
to tell a story.
So I think actually making the
feature film I made on my own
was probably where more of
the trust came from.
Because that was something
that they made that was a
feature-length project.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted to
comment about the "Monsters
University" website being
excellent PR, and
that that was great.
And I'm wondering with the
release of the movie if
there's going to be any
new things up on
the website, surprises.
KORI RAE: Oh man, that
is a great question.
DAN SCANLON: Robin?
Sorry, our PR.
KORI RAE: I know.
It's PR.
I think probably so, yes.
I think they're going to try
to keep that active for a
little while longer.
To be honest we've been just
traveling around Europe the
last few weeks.
DAN SCANLON: Humble brag.
KORI RAE: Oh,sorry.
Humble brag.
DAN SCANLON: It's no big
deal, been to Europe.
KORI RAE: Oh that's
bragging, really?
Shit.
Anyhow, but so I'm not sure
what's happening with it.
But I would imagine that they're
going to put some cool
new stuff on there I hope.
It is great, I love it.
DAN SCANLON: Yeah, me too.
AUDIENCE: Along the lines of
the sequel, prequel, I was
surprised when I looked up that
the original movie came
out in 2001.
And so I think about how much
changed in my life since that
time, because I was in high
school when it came out.
So what is the challenge when
you take for instance that
large amount of time between
audiences and maybe some of
the original viewers are now
going into college themselves.
And then as a quick follow-up
is there a door open for a
return of Mike and
Sully after this?
KORI RAE: Yeah, I mean I think
the fact that it's 12 years
later and a lot of kids were
six or seven when they saw
"Monsters Inc" and are
now going to college.
That totally is a
happy accident.
I know that probably sounds
like a lie but it's not.
It really was the timing
did work out that way.
We didn't even know what the
release date of the movie
would be when we started
talking about it.
That was really a happy accident
that's been fun.
I mean we did a lot of
screenings at colleges and
universities around
the country.
And it was really fantastic to
see the feedback just of kids
who kind of grew up with
Mike and Sully and
now they're at school.
DAN SCANLON: And we're going
to wait another 60 years to
make "Monsters Retirement Home"
so that you can all
relate to that.
We really don't have any idea
for what happens next.
We don't know yet.
KORI RAE: Yeah.
DAN SCANLON: Or if.
KORI RAE: No plans yet.
AUDIENCE: Is this is the first
G rated college movie?
DAN SCANLON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Was that like
a good challenge or?
DAN SCANLON: Yeah.
It is, I mean it is, for
the obvious reasons.
But we realized early on that
what John Lasseter called kind
of the raucous nature of
college, as long as you had
monsters kind of falling down
and smashing things and eating
garbage out of the
garbage can.
It kind of felt like, oh that's
a pretty wild party.
I don't need to know what's in
the red cup, although there
are red cups.
But you know what?
In some ways though, I think
the bigger issue was that
college is what college
movies are about.
And I think that was a tougher
sell in a way.
College movies are about
rebellion and rebelling
against the system.
And without giving anything
away, I mean these guys do
that a lot.
They have to, and it has to be
about kind of bucking the
system a little bit.
And I almost feel like that is
more subversive and harder for
people to swallow because yeah,
a college movie for
parents would be about kids
that go to school and do
great, and get great grades, and
don't have any problems.
And this can't be that.
KORI RAE: Right.
AUDIENCE: This is a
question for Dan.
You mentioned earlier and then
you alluded to it in your
career path, that you made this
movie on your spare time
with other Pixar people?
I wonder if you could tell a
little more of that within the
context of Pixar culture?
Like are there always these
creative ambitious people
doing these side projects?
Or where you really like driven
to figure out how you
could kind of take your career
to the next level?
DAN SCANLON: Oh I think that's
what's great about Pixar is
there's a lot of people
doing that.
KORI RAE: Yeah.
DAN SCANLON: There's always
artists making their own comic
book and people doing
their own thing.
And I think Pixar is really
supportive of it, as long as
it's handled correctly.
Because it's all about like
here, it's all about allowing
people to get better
and explore.
And what better way than for
them to do it on their own
little bit too.
I think a lot of people are
doing those kinds of things
and it does help you grow.
AUDIENCE: With both of you
having been with Pixar since
before the Disney acquisition
and afterwards and with the
purchase of the "Star Wars"
franchise ringing in our ears,
what kind of freedoms and how
did the production process and
creative process change pre
and post acquisition?
KORI RAE: I mean obviously the
biggest thing was access to
the characters and making more
films, sequels, prequels with
those characters.
That was kind of the biggest win
for us because we really
wanted to be able to do that.
But creatively in terms of being
there, we're still so
singularly focused--
I can't say that word--
on just making great movies that
we haven't noticed any
big changes.
I mean when we're heads down
making a movie it's the same.
We're trying to do better each
time and we're trying to tell
better stories and use
technology in a different way.
But in terms of the culture
nothing has changed honestly.
It's been good in that way.
DAN SCANLON: We're
a bigger company.
KORI RAE: We're pretty
autonomous.
I mean Pixar itself is an
autonomous part of the Disney
corporation.
So, and it does feel
like that still.
AUDIENCE: Pixar is known for
having great technical prowess
and then also artistic vision.
So you have these two groups
of people with really
incredible talent.
How do they match up against
one another where you have
people able to do something but
necessarily not having the
vision there.
Or you have people having
the vision but not
the technical ability.
KORI RAE: Yeah.
I mean I think that is
one of the beautiful
things about Pixar.
It was started by John Lasseter
and Bill Reeves,
sitting in a room together--
the artist and then the
technical director.
Kind of sitting there helping
each other solve problems,
creative problems and
technical problems.
And I think that's kind of the
basis of what Pixar what we
were built on.
With kind of that mentality.
So we work really hard to make
sure that that those people do
collaborate.
I mean we have the folks who
are building the characters
and rigging the characters
really in the same room with
the animators to figure
out how best to do it.
And the best shows and the best
departments and the best
movies are the ones who do that
collaboration the best.
And you have to have it.
It's so key because these
films are exactly that.
It is a true marriage of
art and technology.
And you have to have
that collaboration.
And so a lot of my job as a
producer is actually to make
sure that that's happening.
And that it's happening in all
departments and that all
departments are talking
to one another.
So it's really important and it
requires a fair bit of work
and to make sure that
we keep doing that.
DAN SCANLON: And Kori really
made that happen on this film.
It was a big part of what you
brought to the film is that
working together.
I feel like we really had
departments working together
in such a special way
on this film.
And I think it shows
in the final film.
KORI RAE: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
This is such a treat.
Your movies have such attention
to detail, and after
five years and that amount of
focus are there still things
that you look at and you say
I wish wed done this?
Or do you get to do
get to do it all?
DAN SCANLON: Boy, I gotta say
with five years you kind of
get to do it all.
Like sometimes almost to
a nightmarish degree.
You watch each shot so many
times with a room full of
people looking for the tiniest
little mistake.
It's not that I'm saying the
movie's perfect or anything,
but as far as those details
really everybody
just combs over them.
Although it is funny, Leon Kirch
told me, he said, wait
til the movie comes
out though.
People will find stuff.
But we were in a room full
of people looking at
every little dot.
And he's like, they'll find
something and it will be huge
because you were so busy looking
at the one frame that
turned off for a frame, that
you'll miss the fact that he
said in "Toy Story 3"--
I don't think he'll mind-- he
said in "Toy Story 3" somebody
pointed out that at one point
Andy is running around with
Woody or something.
And the camera pans over-- the
entire bed is shoved halfway
into the wall.
And he's like, we watched this a
million times and called out
the tiniest little stuff
and we missed that.
So keep an eye out for
our giant mistakes.
KORI RAE: Yeah, that's true.
MALE SPEAKER: Well it's
interesting about the
communication thing a little
bit because I know the
original atrium at Pixar was
built so that everyone could
meet, eat together, bump into
each other and exchange ideas.
And now it's a far bigger
company in a way.
Does that still happen or is it
a case of sort of making a
point of leaving your office,
walking around, and
interrupting?
KORI RAE: No, it really
does still happen.
And the bathrooms--
that's the key.
It's the food but it's
also the restrooms.
That's where you meet people.
And Steve insisted on putting
them all in the middle, and we
when we were about to move into
the Emeryville campus
from Point Richmond we
were just up in arms.
Like we can't walk that
far to the restroom.
But it actually works.
Well we have a few buildings--
each building is kind
of set up that way.
It really does work.
At the very beginning of
this film we were in an
out-building kind of down an
alley a little away, when we
were in early development.
And we remember the difference
in moving
back to the main building.
How great it was to see
everybody again.
And not be isolated like that.
So it is really important.
You run into people all the
time and it makes you
communicate and talk to people
that you otherwise
wouldn't have seen.
So it's quite effective.
Steve's a smart guy.
DAN SCANLON: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: I guess we talk a
little bit about Steve, that
things must have changed
a little from
that aspect as well.
And also with John because now
he's overseeing feature
animation down in LA.
And then he still manages to--
what's his working day like?
It must be incredible.
KORI RAE: Yeah it's crazy.
He's Superman for sure.
None of us really quite
know how he does it.
But he does.
DAN SCANLON: He does
do it, yeah.
KORI RAE: And he's hands on.
It's not like he's just coming
in and-- he's actively working
on all of the films and the
shorts and everything at the
studio every day.
I think he goes down
to Disney one day a
week or two days sometimes.
But yeah, we checked in with
him at least once a week,
sometimes twice a week, for a
couple of hours and showed him
all stages of production.
Because it's really important
to get his genius eye on
things and to get feedback
from him.
DAN SCANLON: He gives
great notes.
Because he has a distance from
it too that he can really
judge because we've
been so focused.
KORI RAE: Right.
MALE SPEAKER: I did also notice
that there was a recent
announcement that there's
going to be a lot more
features up til 2016.
And films such as "Untitled Film
Number 8," "Untitled Film
Number 9." So do you think one
of those may be yours, or you
hope so, or you'll pitch a new
idea, what will you do?
KORI RAE: Wait, what year?
DAN SCANLON: I don't know.
We'll do the math.
Well let's see.
A year-long vacation.
We don't know yet.
We'll have to see, hopefully.
KORI RAE: Yeah there's a
lot of stuff going on.
And it's really--
we have a lot of projects in the
works and then you have to
see how they pan out.
Because even when you try
scheduling them and say, yeah,
we want this one to
come out here.
Until you get really into it
you're not sure that it's
going to work at all.
So there's a lot of shuffling
that happens before that.
MALE SPEAKER: And sounds as if
that the pitching of an idea--
I kind of got the impression, is
it true that there's three
ideas that you would
take to John?
Particularly if you were going
to work on a short idea for a
movie, that you would approach
the brain trust with three
strong ideas and then possibly
one of those may make it?
Is that true?
KORI RAE: Yeah.
That is, especially
the shorts.
I think that is definitely
how.
And I think it was a suggestion
from John because
it just opens the world
a little more.
And I think they get to see
more of the creative of an
individual.
If they're not--
if these aren't folks who've
directed before or something
and are coming out of
animation or story.
It gives them a wider view of
the total creativity of the
person, to kind of pitch
three ideas.
But it has been successful.
DAN SCANLON: And you're not
putting all your eggs in one
basket too.
KORI RAE: Exactly, exactly.
MALE SPEAKER: We've got time
for two more questions.
Is that OK?
KORI RAE: Cool.
AUDIENCE: With several films
in production concurrently,
how do they interact?
DAN SCANLON: How do
they interact?
KORI RAE: Mostly on the creative
front, getting
feedback on the creative
front.
DAN SCANLON: It's nice because
you can take a little break
from your own movie and your own
problems and go watch the
rough reels of one of the movies
that's coming out two
years after you.
And give notes, and
again share their
problems for a moment.
And selfishly the thing that I
like about it, and I think a
lot of the directors do, is
even as you are doing that
there's a small part of your
brain going, does that make
sense for my movie?
Like when someone says, is
you're hero really being
challenge to the utmost
degree or uses
some crazy story paradigm.
You think, is my hero
going through his
worst possible journey?
And it's just something
to get your mind--
KORI RAE: Yeah, it shakes
things up a lot.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So working at an
animated film studio, what is
it like watching an animated
film by different studio?
What goes through your mind?
DAN SCANLON: I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't see that many
of them lately.
We've been so busy making our
movie we never go to movies
anymore for--
KORI RAE: That's kind of true.
DAN SCANLON: --years.
It's really sad.
Because when I get home
I don't want to
think about a movie.
So instead I watch three hours
of "Pawn Stars" because it's
stupid and it will make
me fall asleep.
And it's terrible.
I gotta start watching movies.
KORI RAE: Yeah.
In a few weeks we'll start
watching movies again.
But it's been a while.
But like anything, I think it's
good and difficult all at
the same time, right?
When you're looking at
your work up against
other people's work.
It's hard not to go there.
DAN SCANLON: The studio, they're
all fans of all sorts
of animation.
KORI RAE: Exactly.
DAN SCANLON: I think people
watch stuff--
KORI RAE: It's a small world.
DAN SCANLON: --and appreciate
the work that's going into it.
KORI RAE: For sure.
DAN SCANLON: We probably
have friends that
work at those studios.
It's all--
KORI RAE: Yeah, it's still
a pretty small world.
MALE SPEAKER: It's been
interesting trying to talk
about the film without
too many spoilers.
But it definitely is an amazing
film and you should
really congratulate yourselves
on that.
And in future, I'll just open
up the floor with about 59
minutes to go and just ask
questions instead, right?
Because they were
great questions.
KORI RAE: Good questions,
yeah.
DAN SCANLON: All right.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you
very much indeed.
DAN SCANLON: Thank you.
KORI RAE: Thanks you guys.
Thank you.
[MUSIC  PLAYING]